>> Bret: FINALLY TONIGHT, IT
IS THE END OF THE WEEK, IT IS
FRIDAY, HARD TO BELIEVE.
WE ALSO HAVE NOTABLE PORTABLES.
>> WHO DOES THIS?
ONLY A MONSTER DOES THIS.
>> LAST NIGHT, PRESIDENT TRUMP
SAID THE FBI RAID WAS A
DISGRACE.
SPEAK OF THE SITUATION IS A
TOTAL WITCH HUNT.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, WILL YOU FIRE
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL?
>> SOMETIMES THEY LIKE TO SAY
YOU FLAT OUT MADE THEM QUIT,
THEY QUIT.
[LAUGHTER]
WE'RE DOING THAT TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE TOO.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO THINK I'VE
DONE MY LITTLE PART IN HISTORY
TO SEND US IN A BETTER COURSE.
>> UNDERSTAND THE TRUMP TRILLION
DOLLAR DEFICIT IS HERE FOR THE
LIFE OF HIS PRESIDENCY.
>> THERE ARE SOME IMPURITIES ON
THE FACEBOOK --
>> THEY HAVE SHUT DOWN THE
CHICK-FIL-A APPRECIATION DAYS.
>> ALTHOUGH HEALED DISPUTE THIS,
I CAN BEAT MY SON IN COURT EVERY